ladies and gentlemen I can with
confidence tell you that we are bringing
it back what is it this shirt honor
shirt is back yes you can buy this shirt
once again and this is the final final
time we are ever bringing back this set
so if you missed out on our drop with
aari we are bringing back all of the
popular items that you enjoyed on screen
right now you can see some of the
pictures of the merchandise we are
bringing back some of your favorite
pieces from that collection and offering
them one last time to you guys again
some of the items are the after dark
hoodies the after dark sweatpants the
after dark split shirt and of course the
lavender shirt the Connor shirt I
already have three of them and the main
reason why we're bringing these back is
because I need 30 more of them so if you
want to get your hands on some of this
iconic merch it is only available for a
very short time so make sure that you
grab it now pre-orders run from January
26th to February 9th PST and if you buy
one of the Connor shirts and meet me in
the Conor shirt I will give you a
picture a handshake and maybe a kiss on
the cheek who knows how Saucy we can get
so I hope that I can expect many of you
at home rocking the Connor shirt very
soon get them while you can now how many
8-year-olds do you think you can
feasibly beat in a fight at the same
time they try to jump you what if I just
like grabbed one kid okay let's say 10
kids run at me I grabb one kid throw
them at the kids to get as many of them
out of the way as I can grab another kid
grab my pile driver's head into the
ground welcome back to another episode
of the trash taste podcast I'm your host
Joey and I'm with my fellow cohorts
Connor and G uh we're going to we're
we're doing a topical episode well we're
going to be doing a normal episode which
has been a while since we've done a
normal episode where we don't come in
with a pre-planned topic we haven't seen
each other in quite a while I believe
right like two weeks yeah we got a lot
to C you're in Thailand I was in
Thailand uh what were you doing just
catching on the family yeah had a big
family reunion and uh just wanted to
chill out in my house in Thailand and
catch up with some friends as well and
pretty much January is the only month
this year um that I'm going to be able
to travel back to Thailand I think so I
was like I got to take this opportunity
but I am pissed off because I missed the
big Geeks plus trip where all of the
company won on this great trip both of
you [__] missed out on it wait what
he didn't go either I I didn't wait what
you didn't go I didn't go no wait you
didn't know I just didn't I had I had
stuff came up no I was busy I I I last
minute had to put together a gaming
tournament yeah he was he was too busy
being a streamer wait
what was that the the Apex tournament
right yeah Apex came to me cuz they had
a collaboration with Final Fantasy yeah
yeah right and I guess I don't know how
I guess you're the final fantasy guy I
don't know how it all came about and I
also don't know cuz I was literally
asked like last minute I don't know why
they were like well I guess maybe they
had like maybe some ad agencies a budget
left over or something yeah and I guess
there was like no one who knew both
games pretty well yeah but I I was
trying to think about it I was like I
don't think there's many streamers who
know Apex really well and no final cuz
it's just completely different audence I
guess I guess you've just got that one
little niche now don't since when are
you the dude that knows Final Fantasy
pretty well oh he's he's completed two
now [__] [__] he's completing more than
me Joey how many how many okay how many
[__] Gamers who play first person
shooters have completed like a final
fantasy all the way through that is true
there not many I feel like at least not
that's the minimum requirement have you
finished at least one final fantasy I
think you'll be hardress only Japanese
vtubers
yeaha well I think that was maybe why
the collaboration came about cuz it was
like obviously I think to a lot of
people in the west they were like what
what what is the it is a weird they
asked me to put together a tournament
last minute uh and it like wasn't even
we were we were trying to get it all
done like wasn't even confirmed until
like literally like two days before did
it go well yeah it went great it was a
fun tournament it worked out really well
and I think everyone had fun um got to
bring out some people who I wanted to
get involved in something for a while uh
and I think people really enjoyed it uh
we got to make sure with these kind of
events that like how do you make a game
maybe people don't really understand how
do you make it like easy to watch that's
always a tough part is Apex difficult to
understand I guess maybe to non- Apex
players yeah if you haven't played Apex
there's a lot of povs going on it's like
how do you you know I think any Battle
Royale or any kind of shooter well and
that's what I feel about firstperson
Shooters as a whole in terms of like uh
an Esports I mean Counter Strike is
still like one of the biggest Esports
but I still always think it's harder to
follow having so many different
perspectives than yeah the perspective
swapping is the perspective that's true
they they added the Buster sword into
the game so you can just go around and
like slash people up it's cool it was
kind of cool I think it's actually ended
by the time that this episode's out but
it was really cool wait yeah cuz I saw I
saw so many uh ads of it in like aabra
dude they was everywhere they went crazy
so weird just seeing like what was it it
was Cloud t for an ath right yeah but
like they looked so different well cuz
it was like I think they didn't want to
do like a fortnite where they're like
Tia's in Apex yeah that would be a bit
weird they were like let's make one of
the characters kind of dressed like them
and it's kind of like if more so if the
character was cosplay yeah yeah cuz I
didn't even recognize like the
characters at first cuz it just looks
completely there's a Barrett skin that
looks really cool though there's a yeah
okay I think Barrett probably out of all
the Final Fantasy 7 characters probably
works the best yeah he looks that cuz
he's already a gun he's already got
[__] gun he's already a gunman in the
game right yeah but I think that
character doesn't use a gun for
[Music]
Noms so he's carrying a gun I'm not I'm
actually not sure I think uh yeah but
then there was also like material bar
just has arms now apparently yeah and
there's also material you can pick up in
the game oh really and like there's like
the little mascot that will follow you
around dressed as Cloud a Lochness
Monster dressed as Cloud it's really
funny it's it's really cool but yeah
it's a cool collaboration that's so
that's why I missed the company thing
which Joey went to
how was it it was really fun uh we all
we all went up to Nago uh to this place
called kamisu uh and it's basically just
kind of this uh big lake that they have
in Nago I didn't know what we were going
to be doing at first but I assumed it
was just going to be a chill thing um
yeah I did I didn't realize until we
went on this trip and I saw how many
people came with us that I'm like wow
this company is really [__] grown
yeah cuz you didn't come to the
Christmas party did you you missed the
Christmas party I missed the Christmas
party but so I came to this one and
there a lot of new faces I hadn't seen
before and I'm just like are these all
our staff like this this is way too many
like three three four years ago it was
just us three and me you know and now
it's like now there was like how many
people was a freelancer I was I was a
freelancer yeah you're a freelancer k
hadn't joined us yet so many people
hadn't joined us yet I think there was
like 28 people yeah showed up to his
name yeah I think we're the office was
Denny's at that point yeah it was the
office was Denny's that's where we had
our meetings it was us three me and the
boss man and Denny that would that would
remember it's it's I always love going
to like company events and just seeing
how mean acts now because she just like
you remember how she was at the
beginning and the way she is now Big
Boss yeah all she does is just stand in
the corner and just look happy seeing
her children just interact with each
other and I don't know if she was like
that at the company party she was
definitely like that at the Christmas
party where she just people watched oh
yeah she was like oh H yes children yes
gather around talk to each other she was
like looking over her Pikmin you know
like all right everyone gather around
here we go yeah so she did she doesn't
specifically do speeches but for that
one instance during I miss the mein
speech man she did a speech and then
Masa did a whole rugo
section so so to explain we have we have
like a domestic guy at like Japanese guy
called Masa really cool dude uh but he I
I guess like studies a Aug um and so he
was like want to explain what rock Rocko
is basically kind of like um you know
anecdotal standup but in a very
traditional Japanese sty traditional um
it's really good like Rocko Shinju
amazing anime if you watch that you'll
understand it but it's really difficult
to do yep especially well uh and so Masa
you know being the typical Japanese man
getting drunk off of one glass of beer
was just red in the face and after the
speech everyone someone mentioned was
just like Mara do some Rocko cuz there
was kind of like a stage uh in where we
were having the dinner and and Mar was
like all right fine he jumps up just
immediately gets into it just off the
top of the dome for like 15 minutes does
this whole just like Freestyle Rocky go
and it was so funny and and everyone was
just like all right all right he can
spit he can do Rocko it was really
really cool um but yeah we got
absolutely shitfaced that night um I'm
so I'm so sad the the topic you
mentioned in Raku as well was pretty
interesting oh yeah yeah yeah what was
the topic you mentioned what was the
topic Pokemon animal abuse Pokémon
animal
abuse wait wait there's a Rocko skit for
Pokémon animal well no there isn't Mara
made it up on the spot so he he he came
up with the theme on the spot told this
whole story about like Pokemon did you
do in Japanese or in Japanese uh and
like he and he came up with like a
proper punch line and everything and
everyone was like oh that was a really
good bit how long have you been working
on that and M was like I just made that
up so Japanese man has one assah and
he's like a rock he unlocks 100%
brain but yeah and then we and then we
had like a little karaoke uh room uh in
the dean that we booked out uh until way
past everything I think I drank like
half a bottle of whiskey that night uh I
was pretty I was pretty hammered pretty
shitfaced pretty shitfaced but uh it was
fun it was fun I heard about the daon
incident what's the daon incident okay
so it was after the it was after the
whole uh karaoke thing right so we had
the room till about originally we had
the room till about 11:00 p.m. but once
11: p.m. hit we were all still going
really hard because we're all [__] face
so somebody called up the the room and
like convinced them to give us the room
till 12 instead but then after 12:00 we
had to go back to our rooms by the time
we all went back to our rooms we were
very very drunk um I think it was Kai
and a couple of other people staff were
like oh let's go do a Comin run so we so
they went down to the comini to buy what
I thought was drinks cuz I stayed in the
room instead uh Cory one of the staff
members came back holding this the
biggest daon that I've ever seen in my
life like I'm like dyon is radish by the
way this white radish that was probably
about this long and about this thick
really thick mama and he just walked
into the room just holding it like a
baseball bat W and I was like Cory did
you get my drinks and he was like oh no
but I got you this Dion and and he just
gave me this massive dieon I'm like bro
you can't do [__] with the D and I'm
like Cory what do you want me to do with
this and he was like it was really cheap
I was like I don't care you didn't get
me my drinks so we were just drinking
hanging out I was sharing a room with um
with Manu Ohara yeah and uh you know
they were in the they were in the
background with dius playing Magic um
and and Cory said all right well we got
to do something about this daon I'm not
taking you back to my room and I'm like
well I'm
not all right well you bought it men
buys a d refuses to take it home you
bought it oh my God what am I going to
do with it and then uh Jordan one of our
new staff members was just like oh you
know what would be really funny and he
grabbed the D on and he slipped it
underneath uh O'Hara's pillow cuz we all
had like cuz we all had uh futons boys
trip kind of like yeah girls are like I
bet he's cheating on me boys are like
what do we do with the D Almighty donon
so he like he slipped it under uh mano's
pillow without him realizing and then we
we took bets we were like let's see how
long it takes for him to notice that
there's a giant [__] dyon under his
pillow woke up the next morning man
hadn't noticed at all until I told him
about it I was like you should flip over
your pillow and he flipped it over the
next morning and he was like the [__] is
this so he slept on a radish the whole
night he slept on a radish the whole
night and then he said and the dead ass
looked me in the eyes and he went oh
that's why my pillow was rolling around
all a no way he like legitimately did
but I think but then I was like was it
not uncomfortable and and you know cuz
you you'd notice if you were sleeping on
a massive a godamn radish and man
unironically who was just like oh no
like I actually really liked the pillow
height like it was it was actually kind
going to go home be like babe I got to
sleep with the
radish I can't get to sleep without my
radish babe I just discovered this thing
just K me out okay Tik Tok life hack
Japan life sleep with a radish ony it is
customary to sleep with a radish in
Japan this sounds like the Japanese
equivalent of you know like British and
Aussie piss heads when they come home
with like a traffic or some sh in Japan
you just come back with a massive R come
back with a 50 dieon but uh we are going
to have a little bit of a detour MH
because we are going to have the first
official ever trash taste sponsored
segments which we normally wouldn't
agree to is it the first one we've done
yeah I think this is the first time
we've ever been the first time we've
ever done this damn all right uh which
we wouldn't normally agree to uh but I
guess Atlas came to us was it Atlas that
came to us specifically SE and Atlas SE
and Atlas uh so SE and Atlas came to us
and said do you want to talk about
Persona 3 uh for 10 15 minutes however
much you want to talk about it and we
were like well we were going to do that
anyway by the time this episode is out
Persona 3 reload should already be out
for you to get yes yes sir uh so Atlas
sent me a Early Access copy of the game
so I've been playing it for about a week
since you guys have seen this video
probably finished it uh by the time
you're seeing this video but as of us
recording it I'm about 10 hours in so
I'm about 12th of the way through the
game uh and I mean how was it what what
can I say that I'm prob that you're
probably not expecting me to say it's
amazing it's so good it's everything I
wanted I as somebody who is never played
a Persona game uh is this a good time to
jump in what's the best way I would
think so okay so since you kind of
missed the the Train on Persona up until
now like even Persona 5 right uh they've
definitely I think took a lot of
influence from just the success of
Persona 5 especially especially when it
comes to like the visuals because it's
essentially they took the Persona 3 uh
story and the the game which shockingly
came out almost 20 years ago Persona 3
originally came out in 2006 I 20 years
ago yeah 18 years ago that game came out
so they took an 18-year-old game and
they basically just completely updated
all the graphics the music the UI to
kind of match more of the style of
Persona 5 uh which for those of you who
have played or seen any of it has some
of the most beautifulu yeah I mean I
just know it through memes then the
[__] gun UI when it's like gun yeah
it's like shoot well yeah you just cuz
it could be used in so many situations
so and you know like uh last surprise
being like a meme song now and
everything and uh you know the UI and
everything being amazing like I I I
don't know how they did it but they've
somehow made in my opinion a better UI
than P5 okay so like this this just
shows how much of jrpg brain Joey has
yeah so Joey gets an early access to a
Persona 3 reload right one of like it it
is one of my most anticipated games this
year because I like Persona 3 is the
only like only like I guess 3D Persona
game that I haven't played yet I played
Four played five and I was going to play
three cuz I've everyone has told me that
Persona 3 has the best story out of
every person not even not even a
question yeah yeah and I was just like
hm this is based on nothing but pure gut
instinct but I feel like they're going
to remake it and C's like G you need to
play person 3 is one of my favorite
games and I'm like no I'm going to wait
they're going to remake it just watch
just watch and so lo and behold it gets
announced last year or the year before
that they're remaking I'm like I [__]
told you I [__] told you those who
waited they're getting like rewarded now
um so I'm really really looking forward
to this one yeah I think P3 what what
makes the P3 story so good in my opinion
is that even in today's standards the
story is actually quite dark uh there's
a lot of like really dark and you know
some like people who don't like P3
necessarily might like just kind of
brush it aside as being like just edgy
but I think like they do it they they
kind of explore really dark themes in a
way that I think makes sense with the
game play and with the story I have a
question Joey say um what is the rough
story um the rough story okay what's the
like set me set me up on this world so
the rough story is uh you are the
protagonist who is starting
moving to a Brand New School uh it's
like kind of like aing person every
personing to
scho me n it down Joey you're being
you're being transferred to a new school
uh but uh the day that you get to your
new school and you're heading towards
your dorm for the first time you step
out of the train station and something's
up something's a bit weird because there
are no people around there are no people
around the moon is out and all of and
there's just a bunch of these weird
coffins that are just strewn all across
the city right so the protagonist thinks
like what the [__] is going on here
right he gets to the dorm and the the
girl there who is like you know there to
welcome her to the dorm is just like
wait how are you how are you here right
now what's going on so apparently
something's up so you find out a little
bit later on that uh every night in this
city for some reason there is this thing
called the dark hour right which is
where midnight every day of midnight uh
the Dark Hour commences where everybody
who has no susceptibility to the Dark
Hour gets turned into coffins and in
their mind they Birmingham
this this is the dark that's what we
call it at
midnight you better going to be endorsed
by the midnight hits is coming we have a
curfew so yeah so basically it's it's
where like basically everybody who gets
turned into coffins during this Dark
Hour doesn't yeah they don't in their
head they don't realize that the dark
hour is happening like for them it's
just like every other night right
because this Dark Hour happens in
between the space of reality and like uh
like fantasy gu and it's this it's this
time uh at the beginning of the story
you don't know why this dark hour is
happening but everybody who's in the
dorm works for this like organization
that fights against like the enemies
that appear during the Dark Hour which
are the Shadows which if you play P5 you
know right that's where the Shadows came
from right so there there's these these
enemies that appear during the Dark Hour
that try and cause Havoc towards people
and like uh you know try and attack them
kind of like psychologically and
mentally um and you notice that
something is happening as well because
like after every day you start to see
people in the city having this thing
called apathy syndrome which is where
like it seems they're kind of turning
into zombies right or they're kind of
like you know apathetic as the name
suggests right so the the group is like
all right what the hell is happening
here so Shadows are doing some you know
deor right so we got to figure out uh
when the Dark Hour hits the school that
you go to turns into uh the Tartarus
which is this like giant Tower basically
that continues on forever and they think
like all right we've never explored this
Tower before something might be up here
we might we might be able to figure out
if we explore this Tower we might be
able to figure out where the Shadows are
coming from yeah what's happening like
let's get to the bottom of this so the
whole point of the game is you play as
the protagonist as you live your
day-to-day life in the school but during
the dark hours you go and explore the
Tartarus which so try and get to the
bottom of like what exactly is happening
um and like you know Persona 4 person 5
all the games that preceded it uh you
know the the game play is split up into
you know two different sections you got
the turnbas combat that where you go to
the Tartarus fight the fight the Shadows
level up do all that kind of stuff and
then during the day there's the uh
social what what do they call it again
uh uh Social Links social yeah the soci
that seems way scarer than any boss
fight to me I got to try and socialize
and figure out that I mean you have to
imagine as well cuz I mean we're set in
Japan that's got to be the hard part as
well for the yeah yeah that's why they
call it that's they turn it into a
gameplay and you know you know people
you know this is an old game too I
completely forgot about this until I
played the the the reload that uh you
know in P5 right a lot you go to school
Monday to Friday and then the weekends
you can do whatever you want P3 you also
go to school on Saturdays oh my God
because Japan used to be a six- day
school week oh wow until they changed it
remember when I Wasing it I was like why
am I in SCH Saturday I'm like oh because
this is in like 2009 when like kids used
to go to school on Saturdays um so yeah
so basically the whole the social link
thing is uh you know you you live your
daily day life in the school you and you
basically get like essentially infinite
amount of choices yeah I mean so you can
like go to the library to study raise
your academic levels which helps you
unlock different things you can hang out
with people to increase social link
which will help you then create stronger
personas in the uh turnbas combat that's
not why we do everything's intrinsically
like we we increase our we increase our
Social Links to get to know the
characters better yes um but they give
you perks like in game in terms like
game mechanics and stuff like that but
some of like increasing Social Links you
can get some really really interesting
stories with these characters that you
might not get to know as well if you
don't do the side quest but the hardest
choice about any like Persona game is
that you only have a limited amount of
time like life right so it's goes
normally like a yeah it goes like a
calendar so you don't have infinite time
yeah I remember seeing the Cal yeah so
you have to choose who you spend time
with or what you do what you do with
that time are you going to raise stats
in a certain uh in a certain place to
you know make the game easier to play or
do you want to focus all your time on
and and to add to that kind of extra
element of choice as well uh they really
try to kind of stick to the reality of
things uh that you would have in every
other thing so for example like one of
the choices you can do is you can go to
this Cafe during the night and you can
either just go there as a customer and
buy a drink and increase a stat or you
can work there as a part-timer to gain
extra stats and get some money but you
can only do it on certain days of the
week yeah so say for say for example
can't do anything on those days and then
yeah and so once you've decided to
choose this one activity whatever it is
then the day is over yeah and you can't
go back to it so it's this really
interesting choice of everyday life it
really is like life like man this sucks
why can't I change my decision cuz you
can't do that in real life you can't do
that in real life right so it's what's
really fun is that you know obviously
the whole you know the the I guess the
RPG element of like you know fighting
monsters leveling up is obviously fun
for jrpg players but it adds this extra
layer of I guess complexity and like
intricacy of of the fact that both of
these seemingly two completely different
game play styles are linked way so the
choices you make in the social linking
and the day-to-day life affects the way
that your characters operate and your
personas operate in the jrpg world and
then whatever you clear in the jrpg
world affects the real world so the more
you clear of the tardus the more things
you can unlock in the real world as well
so it's it's kind of like playing two
games at the same time uh so there's a
lot of things you kind of have to juggle
but after a while you kind of get a good
feeling of like all right well I've
figured out that if I increase a certain
stat then I can unlock different parts
in the real world which will help me in
the jrpg world which will then help me
with to you know increase the social
link which will then help you to create
this Persona so it's all connected yeah
one thing one thing I want to know that
I'm very interested in so I've already
played Persona 5 and Persona 4 yeah but
one thing that always like stood out was
just how like the setting itself so you
talked about like tdus right is that the
main setting of Persona 3 that is the
main setting of I guess the beginnings
of Persona 3 because one thing I always
stood out persona the city of Tokyo was
almost a character in itself and similar
with Persona 4 where has this you know
country like small Countryside town that
was like that was like a character in
itself as well gave it like a really
each game its own identity yeah Persona
3 is kind of set in uh like a little
Port City that kind it kind of looks
like Oda in a sense so like you catch a
monor rail to get to your school and
it's kind of like in this on this island
that's in the middle of this Bay right
so it's it's a different setting to P4
and P5 but it also has just as much
character I think and again with each of
the different locations that you can go
to and unlock there's so much you can do
in even just each of those locations all
real [__] real [__] now yeah who uh
which girl you going to
romance can you only romance one girl
yeah you can only Rance you can only
romance one girl um it's like real
life well in P5 actually you can romance
multiple girls but if you get caught
with it at the
end that's like real life you get
rejected by all of them in the end you
can attempt it you can attempt it to
romance I've tried cuz I was curious and
literally like Valentine's Day hits and
you just get slapped by every single
girl that you romance and then you end
up with no one just like real life um
cuz I know so many of my mates who have
played Persona 3 are crazy about the
redhead girls yeah mitsuru I I know
nothing about her but I've seen her
design which like this and I'm like I uh
so when I when I originally played P3 I
was also a mitsuru girl yeah and I'm
probably going to be a mitsuru girl
again because the redesigns of all the
characters are so [__] nice like they
again they took the kind of it's It's
not to say that like the the visuals
have like you know not aged since the
original P3 it definitely has uh but
they've again took a lot of inspiration
from the look of P5 so a lot of the
characters in this P3 reload have the
same style as P5 which is great if
you've play P5 the character designs
look sick in that yeah it shows how
Joey's mind work works because you know
he got to play Early Access work and the
one thing the one thing that he showed
me was just like the UI it does look
crazy it does look Jo out of anything
out of everything Joey was like yo I
film something cool and I it's it's just
him going through the menu and literally
him
going I it's crazy how like all of Japan
collectively agreed that all of their UI
skill would go into Persona there's no
UI on we can't make websites we can't do
we make like you know internal systems
in companies but we can make a game UI
look like the best you go to your bank
and has the Persona UI like oh my godom
withdraw boom exp they just know how
jrpg mines work they know how much time
you're going to be spending in the menu
so they're like you got to shoot
yourself in the head to get cash
out Persona withdraw cash yeah um so
again like um P3 I think uh I think
Persona fan can agree uh definitely does
have the best stories and I think a
really strong point about the stories as
well is as you said it's the social link
stories it's it's the it's the
individual characters you get to know
throughout the game where you can
increase their Social Links cuz
obviously the more you increase their
Social Links the more of their story you
get to you know explore and I think that
was a really really strong point of P3
that I think personally speaking the
Social Links in P5 were were good I
think they were great but if you compare
it to the ones in P3 you can I think
very quickly tell P3 social link stories
are a lot more interesting and a lot
more again like dark and very very real
like I remember I remember one of the
Social Links I did yesterday that I
started off was uh you you get to uh
talk to this like kind of old couple
that runs a bookstore and yeah and
everyone who's played P3 knows best it's
the best storyline in the game and uh
and I completely forgot how this story
went cuz it's obviously been so long
since I played the original P3 and uh
you know I don't know how much I should
give away I I probably shouldn't don't
give too much but it's a very dark story
line so you can sweet person yeah
they're like the most wholesome old
couple ever that just has like I think
in like level three of the social link
you're just like whoa okay I didn't
realize we're going to go in this
direction holy [__] how how long is
Persona 3 like there's a game like
normally as a main game so I'd say an
average Persona game probably main story
is maybe about a 100 hours yeah because
again likey game yeah because again
there's just so much room for
possibilities you can choose right and I
think a lot of that time is taken up on
just doing all those different types of
things it's really difficult to like
100% it I don't even know if it's
possible to 100% it but because there's
just so much room to do whatever you
want in the game there are so many
different styles of the game you can go
for so like you know technically
speaking you don't have to do any of the
Social Links those are technically
optional like at the end at the
beginning of a day you have the option
to just go home and sleep oh and that
does nothing SS good you can do that if
you want as well that is a start and you
can just completely just focus on
playing the you know the tiess like jrpg
side of things but again what I think
drives a lot of people to like do all of
the social link stuff is the fact that a
it has great stories and great
characters and B it actually helps you
in the long run in the jrpg section yeah
that's cool that it gives you stats and
you can kind of get rewarded for that
it's just one of the most addicting
gameplay loops loops I have played in a
jrpg genuinely and that's why I'm so
glad that I get to experience Persona 3
reload for like the first time um
because you know going back from Persona
5 to Persona 4 Persona 4 like still a
absolutely great game but it was
difficult to get used to all of like the
gameplay stuff that they had like you
know implemented in implemented in P5
that wasn't in P5
to3 was I don't know if I'm think person
is one of those few games that is really
difficult to go backwards in uh like if
you are going to like experience put so
much like experience and knowledge into
improving the gameplay every single
exactly exactly and I think P3 reload
did such a good job of that of like
taking all of the [__] that they
implemented in P5 that worked so well
and just translating that over to the
story of P3 yeah forgetting I've watched
the anime 7 before but I can't remember
anything oh the Persona the Persona 4
anime yeah I watched all of it Persona 4
was kind of like more of a murder
mystery small little country town I do
remember that I remember this big guy
who was and this big teddy bear being I
was like who's they going to the
television the
television and and the weather the
weather of the day determines the inside
yeah which was a really really cool
concept I think um and P3 does kind of
have something similar to that uh so so
in P5 for instance they also added that
weather mechanic well in P3 uh they have
something a little bit different where
it's the phases of the moon that's yeah
so depending on which phase of the moon
you go into the the dungeon yeah changes
certain elements of I think they did a
little bit of that in uh P5 as well with
um the what was that underground section
MOS yeah momentos they they the MOs so
the experience of momentos is kind of
similar to talus in the sense that every
single Flor is generally proced got to
write all these words down
so so the tus the floors are are
procedurally generated so every single
time you go in it's completely different
yeah um but it's and so that kind of
keeps the whole exploration of the tower
still pretty fresh uh but just with the
added benefits this time of the Godlike
graphics and the music oh my God mear Ro
shoi never [__] misses cuz he I think
from what I saw they re-recorded all of
the P3 music and kind of did a modern
Twist on it and
it's fire I mean like the entire Persona
series as a whole is just like
Aesthetics man oh my God like music it's
just so bloody stylized to like the tea
and uh every game has a different
identity visually audibly and uh with
the story as well which is uh yeah I'm
very very excited to play it I'm
definitely going to be playing it it was
one of my most anticipated games and I
was be the first Persona game Conor
plays I'd I I mean I want to I there's
just a little daunting cuz I like doing
RPGs in one sitting right and 100 hours
in one sitting sounds like blood clots
in my leg I don't it's like not a normal
way to play these games but I like I
like getting sucked into these worlds
and just not leaving yeah I like being
just completely my only thoughts this is
my experience with like every like all
the Persona games i' played like you'll
play like the first few hours and then
they'll reach this point in the gameplay
Loop where your calendar just open op up
right and you have you you'll be
introduced to like one thing you'll do
like okay maybe I can do this one social
link or go to the library of this one
day and then you'll get to this point
about I I would say like 5 to 6 hours
into any Persona game where it just
opens up and you're like [__] there's so
many things I want to do and then you
have to make the hard choice of being
like no but I want to do it all well I'm
I'm currently about 9 10 hours in and
there are still a couple of shops in
like the main mall area that aren't even
open yet yeah I don't I don't really get
decision fatigue when all the
information is given to me I hate it
when there's like kind of like there's
three paths we don't tell you anything
pick one I'm like oh God oh God oh I
mean Persona is that but it's 30 parts
oh okay I mean if I know what all the
things are I feel like I can make a
decision but then when they don't tell
me anything about any of the paths I'm
like huh so what's also kind of cool as
well is that I think they really thought
through about like the whole decision-
making process because they also kind of
on certain days they put Stakes on
certain decisions right in the sense
that like for example like uh every
morning when you wake up or after school
rather every day uh you wait you you
know you enter the afternoon phase where
you can do whatever you want in the
afternoon and you know you have a list
you can be like oh you know maybe I want
to increase this stat so I'll go to this
place maybe that's already predetermined
in your head but then you can open up
your phone and you can see that you
received some text messages from some
people
oh and if you cancel them it might
affect your social link with that's like
real life just like real life but if you
respond back to the text messages on
that afternoon you get an extra perk in
the social link it's like real life
which is like real so now you have to
think to yourself well [__] I was going
to go I was going to go to this Cafe
this afternoon to increase my you know
charm stat when your homie texts you
thank you for everything you know you
know it's [__] up because I think G
probably applies quicker in Persona to
the m than he does in real life to
us KH is like a 4day reply guy like I
may well write a [__] pigeon
messenger to go yeah right if if I could
see the social link
increase G just needs like his like
brain UI to have like the text message
right there being like oh [__] I got to
respond yeah so I mean again you know
having played uh the original P3 uh you
know they've obviously changed a couple
of things um I think one of the
mid-level bosses they made it a lot
harder in this one which I was surprised
about um and I think some of the the
finer details of the story L as far as I
can remember are a little bit different
but doesn't still feels like a P3 game
with just with now it's hard it is it
can be pretty challenging I'm yeah I'm
I'm just playing on normal difficulty
right now just so I can kind of get a
sense for all the changes that they have
but like you can go like hard or like
very hard mode which very hard mode in
any Persona game is like actually very
hard it's even for an experienced player
that [__] is hard so if you want to
challenge yourself to that I yeah I like
doing it I like I like um RPG combat cuz
the way they just kind of make you have
to you have to rest your team it's more
about thinking how everything works
together Asos brute forcing yeah I mean
Persona 5 is the game that Sol me on
turn base combat systems all right well
also just just me personally my favorite
thing with P3 is uh you buy all your
weapons from a police
officer hell yeah like there's a police
officer in the police station and he
takes you to the back room he's like all
right what do you
want so that's do but yeah uh [__]
amazing I'm obviously going to finish it
uh and I'm having a really really good
time with it went way over what we were
paid for to talk about in this uh
sponsor seg leg we just really wanted to
talk about it but uh yeah either way
guys uh by the time you're watching this
episode uh p3r is out right now on all
of these systems put them on the screen
M on cuz I don't remember all the ones
that they have there uh and you can
check out the link in the description
below as well if you would like to uh
check out P3 if you never played Persona
trust me I think this is the best game
to jump into uh just play Persona just
play a [__] Persona game they're all
great but if you want to jump in this is
the perfect opportunity so yeah again
guys if you'd like to go check out the
game then the link is in the description
below on screen uh it is a bitly link
bit.
l/t p3r in all caps again go check it
out go play g go play the game cuz it's
amazing just go just do it just do it
what are you waiting for just go do it
right now we convince Conor to do it I'm
going to convince I I do I do I do
actually want to play up yeah so yeah
thanks for letting us talk about the
game and thank you to se and Atlas for
this part of the video yes I appreciate
it I mean what a dream come
true finally it only took me 10 years of
loving Atlas in order for me to get this
wait you got paid to talk about Persona
Joey I got paid to talk about a series I
love it's quite rare CU actually there's
um there's uh a lot of the time I mean I
guess this is this is not not part of
the sponsorship now but they're like
actually kind of talking about it where
like a lot of a lot of people get really
annoyed when um people who get sponsored
by games or series that haven't watched
it and they're like well you should
sponsor you know like Joey from Bic he
always plays B uh but I guess the a lot
of the times people fail to appreciate
that a lot of the times sometimes
companies are trying to get like new
people in and if Joey is running the um
I don't know the Persona the Persona 3
Fan Channel and everyone's like why
isn't the Persona 3 Channel being
sponsored It's like because everyone's
already going to play it well yeah and
it's kind of the harsh reality really
you almost you almost like don't get
these opportunities sometimes if you're
too into the thing that is true that
kind of weird there was uh some news
that uh people were very pissed that uh
xqc was uh promoting Yakuza series wait
was he yeah he got paid to play the yuza
series oh [__] and uh I think people
just hate xqc well okay so there's that
there's that which is fair but people
were like people were getting very upset
they like why is he getting it when uh
this other streamer who streams all the
games didn't get it and it's like well
you just answered your question he
streams all the games he's going to he's
going to play the whole [__] although
I will say I don't see xqc as a media
fan base being like this looks like a
pretty good game well he he he was like
there was like a a clip making the
rounds right he was playing the game and
he didn't realize it was turnbas combat
yeah and it was like he was it was kind
of a funny I don't know if you can pull
can you pull it up type an sqc you wait
is it was he playing seven or the new
one the new one what's the new one um
eight or it's like a dragon dragon like
a dragon yeah but it's it's um type in
sqc 8 turn based literally the first
video is why I think xqc was an odd
choice to play yua eight early I mean it
definitely is is cuz I think his fan
base just isn't yeah look at this there
articles about it like a dragon fans not
happy about sqc being used to promote
again another game I need to play I
think that actually came out today as of
us recording this I think the the main
issue I think with getting oh this one
yeah look at this one holy okay perfect
guard press o on perfect
guard I mean I have to
double I can't even understand what he
what I'll try
again come on do it he's got to attack
CU it's his
turn okay then oh my God you know to be
fair I I I think momentarily not
understanding something in a game is
it's [__] it's it happens to everyone
you for a moment you could not realize
that yeah I think I think a lot of
people get annoyed because it's like I
guess him well he doesn't really do this
well maybe he does I don't I I don't
watch him enough to know but I know that
his audience uh is pretty much anti not
anti- wee but like generally make fun of
a lot of anime fans people who are kind
of fans of these kind of games so I
think that's why it almost feels like a
slap in the face to a lot of fans of the
series it's that like hey you have these
people who are kind of just toxic online
and hate [__] anyone who likes anime
or like calls it like dumb wee [__] and
it is frustrating to see that almost
being rewarded I think yaka especially
like the franchise has a very much like
I would say a cult Abed
um and seeing your beloved series being
promoted on a completely different kind
of like audience and like different
audience members with completely
different values and everything
sometimes you can get protective over
your Series yeah it's it's kind of like
that it's it's kind of a little bouncing
act you have to do sometimes where
you're like okay I want this thing I
love to get popular but there are some
points there are some points where it
gets like a bit too popular and you're
like okay I wanted it to be popular not
mainstream you know well this this is
how I feel about anime sometimes as well
cuz I'm I'm still like very anti against
like gatekeeping anything like that I
think for example anime getting more
popular more mainstream on the most
Parts uh for like there's there's uh
there it brings more positive things to
the medium as a whole sure but sometimes
I see [__] how Judit kaon fans act
nowadays I see what's happened to my LED
one piece fan base so wholesome before
and I'm like oh okay I'm I'm very very
happy that these things I'm loving are
getting more popular and more recognized
and then you have like the negative
aspect of it yeah it's it's getting more
popular and more recognized by people
outside of the immediate fan base which
you know on the positive is it creates
new fans for whatever that thing is but
at the same time it also lets people who
were probably never anticipating to like
this thing to realize that this is a
thing yeah and then getting all piss
pissy about it because I guess they
don't like it or whatever I feel like
anime is just is just now becoming very
very similar to how gaming fandom is
kind of treated where it's like you know
people who are into pubg have no
interaction with a Nintendo fan of
course you know I mean and it's kind of
like that CU it's like all right well J
Jutsu kaon is just pop culture at this
point it is just like one of the most
wellknown
is dude the Jutsu Kon memes never end
they are just Relentless and I'm I love
it it's great like it's they're funny
and I think it's kind of like that now
with where a lot of like anime fans are
kind of struggling to kind of like come
to terms the fact that maybe their anime
fandoms are kind of going to be split
like similarly to how gaming kind of is
yeah I think eventually if it hasn't
already happened like it's already
happened with the big franchises you
know like obviously you know you have
the one piece fans only interacting
usually with just the one piece fan and
like creating these smaller Echo
Chambers I guess of like fan bases which
you know 5 10 years ago when you know
when I was starting off like there was
nothing like that you could be like oh
have you are you watching this whereas I
feel like the public Zeitgeist of like
judu kaon fans I don't even think they
know what a free Ren is like a lot of
them like but I also think that like
there is this weird genre of anime fans
who think that other like if they watch
like a show like Jud Ka all these kind
of very very very AAA shown in titles
they still think that like something
like Freer ran is weeb [__] yeah they're
like that's [__] gross wee [__] I'm
going to go watch the jut kais now where
the panda uses the sorcery magic you
know what I mean it's kind of bizarre
like it's kind of I have seen the
sentiment there are so many anime fans
like that caliber now that just think
that anime is shown and [__] and
everything else is like as you said it's
like strange it's like it's like we are
not the same I've legitimately seen
people who are like Ming Jud kaon I'm
like I like who then have no knowledge
of what like a like a free or a through
Diaries which is so insane to me because
this 5 years ago this is just if you
watched any of these shows you knew knew
about all the other big shows were
happening at the same time absolutely
and I think that's kind of like what's
almost happening in this example is that
like but there there's also multiple
layers to this like I think a lot of
people who are pissed off about X
streamer or X content creator getting a
sponsorship to X game or watching watch
along X Game X gam oh God like this one
it's like okay but it not to I'm I'm not
defending him because I don't I don't
care but uh from the perspective of like
how these ad agencies work how these
deals work a lot of the times uh whoever
publishes uh like a dragon or whatever
will just go to a big Ad Agency and be
like find me a bunch of creators who are
going to play my game here's the budget
just go and find as many yeah and then
there's agents so now the agents are
vying so there probably like multiple
layers yeah it's not like the like a
dragon craters went we want I mean that
does happen though that can happen it's
very rare though that that does happen
probably happened is that there was
budget flying around someone some agent
managed to convince some agency and then
that's how it ended up happening for
sure and I think I think you know people
are mad and I think that's fair I think
it's uh that there is some justification
to being mad that some content creators
get to it's fine the game is out now if
you don't want to watch
xtram but then it's also dumb as [__]
cuz you can also just not watch yeah
that's the thing it's like it's I don't
yeah like again like I I get why people
are angry at this but at the same time
it's like it's not like this kind of
content is being like thrown in your
face where you have where it's like TV
and it's unavoidable you know like you
can choose just not to watch this oh
also I think the as this article points
out one of the things people were very
annoyed about is that he had been very
negative towards these types of games in
the past which I think so it's a little
cont it's kind of insulting yeah to fans
who which I think that that's completely
valid I think it's being annoyed about
this in that context is very annoying
especially if if he has called them
trash which this article is claiming
yeah um also I want to give a quick
shout out while we're on that topic uh
of the fact that my friend is in this
game oh yeah Sophie you can you can date
Sophie in the game oh [__] also I think
is is K in this one too is it was the
other one yeah she's in this one too
she's a yeah she's a I think she's in
the other there's a there's a bar game
yeah right she's one of the wasn't this
game I thought it was the previous one
dude there's so many y there is yeah I
mean there's like 10 now isn't there
yeah what's what's confusing is that
haven't they released like two or three
different games now in the space of like
a very short period of Time how do I how
well they've done remakes of old games
the [__] I'm trying to keep track and I
K's in one of them I'm like which one
are you in K yeah so kon's in like uh
sorry in the the previous one yeah the
seven seven guy then right yeah and
she's also in this one as like a
character in the game she's like one of
the uh is it like a kakura or something
kind of okay okay okay which is so
[__] funny that's so cool she's like
an actual character in this one right
yeah yeah cuz Sophie is in this one but
it's like actually a a picture of Sophie
in real like it's it's a dating app like
part of the game and one of the girls
you can date on the dating app is
literally just a picture of my friend
funny which is really funny so good on
yourself that's so cool I'm again like
dude jrpg eat uh jpgs jrpg fans are
eating so well in February cuz you know
we have p3r we have Yak 8 we got [__]
uh Grand blue we got fin Fantasy 7 God
when does it end I don't have time to
play all these games bro you actually do
not you you actually don't but I will
find the time to do it you have the time
in the entirety of uh 2024 the year yeah
yeah yeah yeah this is this is why like
man I just it's stressful being a gaming
fan now cuz like everyone's arguing at
each other like you got to play this you
didn't play this game it's like I only
have so many hours in this anime fans
like first
time first time first I'm trying to be a
jrpg fan and I'm trying to be a gaming
fan I'm trying to be a film fan I'm
trying to be now you know why jrpg fans
are Tre Just J jpg like that's just why
and it's like it feels impossible now to
be multifaceted in media and like being
able toally enjoy multiple media
absolutely and I'm trying my best to be
all all the above yeah because I go to
the movies like every week as well and I
still feel like I'm I'm behind on movies
but you don't want to spread yourself
out too thin yeah yeah I'm I I am just
do what you enjoy that's that's what ENT
the guys [__] keeping up with whatever
current I had this like Epiphany where I
was like no I think I'm actually a
gaming addict I think I can't stop
gaming like I think I'm genuinely
addicted to gaming it's all I want to do
in my free time that's fair I all I want
to do is listen to music yeah yeah true
I just want to watch anime that's we are
we are same same but different same but
different you know I might go out and do
some you know different things you know
watch hasbin Hotel the other day uh wait
what yeah watch hasbin hotel is is it
good
um I am not the target audience for okay
I don't know anything about this I know
the name and the fan base is kind of
notorious I I don't yeah I have no I've
known nothing about it but all I see is
that people get pissed off about Twitter
I don't know about what I see people get
pissed off and I don't know what cuz it
nothing I don't know anything about
what's going on in Twitter I mean
Twitter's pissed off against Twitter's
pissed off against like everything El
but I feel that's one of those fan bases
where you hear so often and the only
times I hear about it is because some
controversy is happening within the
community I have no idea yeah I no I can
understand maybe why because you know
this this kind of show um
I think that with how many eyes it has
on it and the kind of people that you
know this kind of show attracts there's
a lot of there's going to be a lot of
discussions about a lot of things
especially on a platform like Twitter um
I came into it because Sydney showed me
the pilot [__] years ago I'm like oh
that's that's that's pretty cool I'm not
really like musicals aren't really my
thing actually I might I might slowly be
see I didn't even know it was a musical
yeah yeah so so okay here here's the
thing it's kind of like it it it selling
point is that it's an adult musical kind
of like it's an adult animated musical
right about these you know characters in
hell that uh want to get promoted to
Heaven basically and that's kind of like
the it's kind of cool concept kind of
like the elevator picture uh it's got a
really cool aesthetic I really like the
aesthetic um and you know I wasn't
really into musicals until I saw
Hamilton with d and Emily and I didn't
like it at first and then I just found
myself continually it every so often
Hamilton is such a good
musical it's like unironically a bang of
Music don't really like musicals I don't
really like musicals either I'm picking
choosing with musicals but Hamilton was
goed Hamilton I think worked for me cuz
it just felt like a meme you
know that's why almost I didn't want to
watch it cuz it felt so people were so
upset about everything like they were
because they like it so much and they
were getting so angry about people not
liking it and I was like man dude the
raps are fire though I will say that the
songs are kind of fire but they're also
kind of funny at the same time like
there's this one song in Hamilton where
it's it's the a song that revolves
entirely around writing essays right and
they try to Hype up this moment where
like okay Hamilton wrote all of these
documents and like they were like okay
we're writing we're writing these essays
all right we're writing these documents
we split into three people all right
this guy he wrote five essays this guy
he wrote 10 essays and then everything
like and then he pauses for a second and
then Hamilton wrote 21 essays I can't
remember the exact number but I remember
hearing that and the moment it's propped
up at this moment being like oh [__]
man's can
right I I don't know it's it's it's just
the right amount of campiness that okay
it's like if it's like if your English
teacher was in a rap battle you know
yeah but you wrote 21 essays you're weak
oh all these like dudes in like 17th
16th century clothing just be like oh
[__] yeah it's so funny so I don't know
like I at the beginning I I walked out
of Hamilton and I'm like yeah it was all
right and then like I keep I keep
thinking about certain moments in it and
I'm like okay that's a lot of it to
something yeah so I ended up watching a
bit of hasbin hotel with Sydney cuz we
were both like curious about it um and
one thing it made me realize right cuz I
said as I said it me it's meant to be
like an adult musical uh so there is a
lot of swearing in it okay um and it
made me realize how weird it is to hear
especially like an American you're going
to say this an American piece of media
like a fictional media with so much
swearing in it sure and I don't know I I
kind of didn't like it really cuz CU
like doesn't suit the American I don't
dialect as well you know sometimes you
hear a sitcom and what about like South
Park that is a lot of swearing is it
I feel like southp kind of works cuz
it's
kids in a weird way it feels like I
could believe 13-year-old kids wanting
to swear all the [__] time yeah I
think they're like I think they're like
10 in the show oh yeah actually they are
I feel like it's so Preposterous and so
ridiculous that it works I don't know
because like has his own weird sometimes
I hear like I see like a [__] guy
Richie film or something and you know it
it it works for something like that you
hear it in like a British
UK yeah yeah it just adds I don't know
it adds character to it whereas you know
with just a neutral American accent like
if you like if you see like a New York
accent or Boston accent all right I'm
like okay that fits but just like a
neutral American accent that youd
normally hear on like a Saturday morning
cartoon sure and you're hearing like
characters say [__] and I remember there
was one moment where one of the
characters Dropped a seab Bomb and me
and C just me and cdy just like we
literally just like felt it in our
bodies we're like oh we just shuted oh
oh did you did you hear the filthy
language that is definitely huh is it's
just all right uh so I've seen the first
three episodes yeah it's all right if if
you're into musicals I think that this
definitely uh you know I can't wait for
the hman hotel Community to come and
defend themselves I don't I don't
[__] care dude I mean I don't care
either I don't think also people who
watch on YouTube give a [__] I think
it's just sometimes sometimes our Clips
find their way on Twitter and people
like what the [__] did these guys
say yeah I I mean the reason we ended up
watching it was because of that big uh
big meme of that one YouTuber who paid
50k oh my God Hotel animation my God
okay conspiracy theory
time that controversy came out just as
hasbin Hotel was being released like you
think it was an inside job I don't know
is it an inside job I don't know man I
think the story probably took up cuz
people were probably very interested in
hasbin hotel and just was like the V
diagram of [__] interesting weird
story to pop off I remember I remember
our friend D sent me that on Discord and
he was just in all caps he just said
what is blood
doing I props to him I mean dude if you
got 50 bands to spend on
gooning I think respect I'm like it
wasn't it wasn't even hardcore it wasn't
even hardcore um likeon is wild it was
like a like like a Mariah Carey video it
was like it was just sensual enough for
some people you know yeah yeah just was
it YouTube safe it's just about YouTube
just about on thep but it was because of
that that me and sdy got curious and I
was just like wait a minute wait this
just released like today as all this
that's interesting because I had the
opposite effect of that where I watched
that and I'm like I'm not watching this
show if this is if this is what the
result of that show is and that fan base
is not to say all the fan base like that
but you know I think you know Standalone
like kind of controversies that in any
kind of like media franch you Fane like
when that [__] pops out you're kind of
just like I'm sure this is an exception
but it had to come from somewhere right
so I it makes me afraid to like step
into that fan base immediately from
there but I mean like huge props to to
the Creator because the creator of
hasbin Hotel I mean seeing I the only
reason I know about hasbin hotel is
basically because of Sydney um and just
you know seeing like her work of on this
for years since like finishing art
college or something cuz she's about
like our age I think right uh she
started off I think I don't know the
entire law of hasman hotel but I know
she either posted her work on Tumblr or
early YouTube and it just [__] blew
up hell yeah and seeing seeing like a
content creator you know just with pure
passion work on this one project for
ages and be able to sell it to Amazon
Prime and still have like a big hand in
it I know there's there was a lot of
controversies for whatever reason maybe
they're just getting angry about stuff
for the sake of getting angry but I know
that they did I think when they when it
went to Amazon they replaced the whole
cast yeah they did which I think annoyed
a lot of people as well yeah um which is
understandable I mean that's generally a
not a good move to do but I'm not sure
sometimes shows have requirements that
could be like hey everyone has to be
Union or hey I don't know why it's seems
odd but hey it is what it is hey still
ended up being successful right I I
watched a musical I didn't know it was a
musical
I watched the new Wily Wonga movie oh is
that a musical I I I didn't I've watched
the original I completely I never think
of Whitley woner as a yeah I never think
a yeah same here a lot of musical
numbers in that yeah and so I watched it
and surprisingly pretty good the Timothy
sham okay actually not to not to be that
guy he's I I felt like he was the
weakest part of the film really I don't
know if I'm crazy I I just Wonka is a
weird guy to me and he plays him as like
this kind of could do nothing wrong fun
happy guyy and I feel like woner in the
original film The Jun Wilder film is
such a [__] weird you've all watched
it right he's such a weird dude Jean
Wilder and he comes off as almost like
not not Sinister but like he's a he's a
kind of [__] up dude in the film oh
yeah uh like his his he kills children
yeah well he's very he's a child
murderer it's like he's kind of a just
an uncomfort like I think we all know
someone or met someone who's like really
nice but also kind of make gives you a
weird vibe but I feel like that's what
Wonka would be in real life like you're
like I don't know why Wonka gives me the
creeps but there should be a creep there
but uh the cast is really good Wonka the
kind of Dude to like laugh at awkward
situations you you know the the main bad
guy is the is Johnson from Peep Show and
he's so good yeah he's so good there's
so many really good British actors that
I
love Hugh Grant Olivia Coleman isn't
itman uh the actors are really good but
yeah Hugh Grant plays the Umpa limpa
which is uh which is an interesting
choice Keegan Michael key is in that
yeah yeah yeah can you type in Hugh
grantpa Lumpa it's very bizarre yeah I
saw it in the trailer [__] weird like
I I remember the first time I saw this
trailer cuz Aki really wanted to watch
it I I did a [__] Double Take when I
saw hug cuz he's right at the end of the
trailer I was just like that's an odd
Choice going for Grant and making him uh
I love it I look at him yeah I don't
understand this choice but hey it was it
was cool it was fun I liked I actually
kind of liked hukan as this character
but it did strike me as kind of odd he's
like a
gigachad yeah well he's kind of like a
[__] Navy SEAL jack of all trades in
this movie for some reason right um but
it was a fun movie uh nonetheless much
better than I thought it was going to be
and you know what it was dead there was
no I I I was just me in this movie
theater really and it was like the week
it released in Japan so I guess they
have no [__] interest in this I don't
think Willie woner is even like a a well
established character that Japanese
people know of well here's what's funny
is that I asked my Japanese friend I was
like hey do you like do you want to go
watch the new you want film and they
were like oh uh yeah I've seen the
original I really like um Jack not Jack
Black um uh Johnny I really like Johnny
Depp in the original I was like that's
not the original no no I was like that's
not the original and then it occurred to
me that most people only know Willie
Wonka from Johnny Depp the Tim Burton
film yeah they only know that version
they didn't even know there was the
which to be honest compared to the Gene
Wilder version not that great in my
opinion yeah I mean I haven't watched I
seen thee Wilder version I think most
people in America in the UK have only
watched the G wild which is very iconic
well it's because like as much as I like
Johnny Deb I don't think he was a very
good I I I don't know I think the the
Johnny Depp woner film just felt too
much like a Tim Burton film you know
what I mean where it's like it was so
iconically Tim Burton that you're like
oh yeah I forgot this is a [__] Wily
Wonka film yeah but you know what was
full I went to watch watch another movie
full could not like it was so hard to
get a seene and you will not you will
not guess which film it was uh it was
Reservoir Dogs Wait what yeah they were
playing Reservoir Dogs in a Japanese uh
in Shinjuku like one of the Shinjuku
theaters and I wait Japanese film gos
kind of Bas though like I watch even
though qu Tarantino is one of my
favorite film I'd actually never watched
Reser really never seen it I just never
got around to it I don't know what do
you think of it it's funny I just showed
I just showed C it a month ago [__]
amazing yeah great aming but it was
insane cuz I kind of rocked up just I
rocked up 10 minutes late from the
screening time pretty much the movie
just started literally I walked in as
they were doing the walk yeah oh you
missed the C you missed the cafe scene
uh yeah and I went home and watched the
cafe scene which I liked as well and
that was really fun but I missed the
cafe scene cuz I was late cuz I was I
was trying to get I was trying to buy
Emily some some birthday early birthday
presents cuz I found a strawberry thing
that was perfect anyway so I was late
and I walked in and dude it was like a a
mission itself sou get in my seat cuz it
was totally full damn um and I was kind
of shocked cuz I haven't seen Japanese
theaters this full since I watched
Godzilla minus one right uh and even
before then I hadn't seen a full but it
was yeah insane full movie for Reservoir
Dogs in this year insane it was a great
movie as well it was really cool getting
to watch I feel like a film like this on
the big screen I feel like when you
watch kind of these old it's kind of
weird cuz I when you watch the classics
you kind of forget that we never really
will ever get the chance to experience
them in the theater sure God there are
so many films would love to experience
in the theater even like like in
glorious bastards or pul fiction I'd
love to be to I'd love to watch theater
screen with a popcorn like movie popcorn
and uh it was really cool getting to
watch that I don't know why Japan does
this why do they just randomly I know
this is very common in the UK and
America they often have some theaters
that just replay Classics uh which
please keep keep doing uh I know a lot
of smaller theaters in Japan do that for
uh you know select films but only with
very very limited huge theater it's the
Shinjuku uh world it's one of the
opposite the the the Toho one oh yes yes
yes so you kind of walk out walk down
the street and it's right yeah yeah it's
in s and I go there quite a lot CU it's
justy yeah that's a really good one um
yeah cuz they they got it's the AA film
there I think yeah it's kind of great
they play so many films and and if the
good thing about that area is that if
you want to watch movies in Japan which
I recommend doing actually because it's
much better than Europe like America I
think America is actually better America
figured out the ideal Cinema experience
of course they're like they're like full
relaxed chairs actually Shinjuku they
released they they released they opened
up the kabuko tower this giant [__]
Tower that's got tons of cool thing and
they have their own premium Cinema I do
quotation marks cuz um uh I is it not
premium well it's kind of hard to to
think of it as like they they're
marketing this as like the gigachad go
theater experience of Japan I it's
pretty big and it is cool and there is a
there's a section that cost like hundred
bucks right right 100 uh sorry uh 10,000
Yen nearly nearly yeah it's about 80 70
bucks so it's about $60 right $607 and
what you get in is that you get your own
booth and before it you get a lounge
experience so you can go to this Lounge
have a drink popcorn is free um it's
like so it's like a business Lounge at a
Naple but kind imagine a business lounge
and then you can this is it yeah this is
it it's literally a business Lou an
airport so you can just have unlimited
popcorn and it's kind of small though
and so here's where I I this the
honestly the sole reason I don't go back
is because you can only take one popcorn
into the theater it's kind of small and
you can't refill it once the movie
starts and it's it's and to me it's like
dude I want popcorn throughout I will I
will get buy like way more popcorn than
I need cuz I just want to be I want to
be going at it um but you get these
booths that uh uh it's kind of I don't
know if you you can type in kukur to
cinema Booth chairs you get this booth
and it reclines but it only reclines
like a desk chair amount it doesn't
fully recline like the American ones I
can basically lie down yeah uh and I
feel like for the amount I'm paying it's
not really worth I mean there's not even
a picture I'm sure it's like premium for
Japan right for Japan it's premium yeah
uh but I feel like for 60 bucks it's
kind of not worth it's none of
those those are the basic chairs which
are pretty good they recline a little
bit of out there's one oh is that it
there uh uh up no you have it two more
one more yeah this is it this is it
that's the booth oh okay okay but it
only reclines like an average desk chair
would recline like this your legs go off
a little bit but not it's at the angle
that's like economy on a on an like a
plane where just it reclines but it's
just like not enough to like you're like
I'm still definitely sitting up it's
kind of like halfway and the legs only
come out slightly so you don't even feel
like your legs are really being
suspended by the chair still like it's
in this weird halfway where limbo yeah
and I this is such a nitpick but I think
for $60 you should be like giving me
like in America I could pay $20 for a
full reclining Godlike [__] like
chair that's amazing and I could [__]
go ham and then obviously I pay SE for
the popcorn but then afterwards they
have this uh actually it's kind of cool
after the cinema there is this Lounge
you can go to a different Lounge you pay
if you pay extra for the S tier you go
to the top of the Cabo Tower B basically
and there is this uh kind of other
Lounge that is just like yeah there's a
giant window and you can just see um I
think uh Nish Nishi Shinjuku station all
the trains going and see like a really
cool view of Shinjuku wait what oh
that's it that's it that's it that's it
no no no no down that one that one yeah
click it yeah that's that's it I mean
that's cool and all but like you get one
free drink it's an alcoholic you be
alcoholic but I mean okay look that's
cool I get it kind of but at the same
time it's like you know know what are
you going to like you just finished
watching a film right here here's what I
think the idea is what are you going to
do you're going to sit there in the
lounge and being like so what did you
gentl think about the mov I think that's
the point I think the point is you watch
you discuss it I think you watch the so
let's say on let's say you go for dinner
uh and then you go and watch the movie I
think it's meant to be like the day like
it's the day I actually like I I kind of
vibe that cuz you it was kind of nice
you you know like sometimes sometimes I
do not like when you you know you plan a
cinema day with your mates or something
then you just leave and then you watch
the film you like hype up the film and
then everyone's like all right I'm going
to go home now and I'm like I feel like
I've missed half of the experience cuz
the whole point of watching with mates
is so you can banter about it afterwards
if I wasn't going to do that I would
have just gone by myself you know but I
I banned her about it on the way to the
station sorry I I Bann if it's a really
good film and you need like 2 hours to
unpack it with well then what I'll do is
I'll go to like a cafe near the station
yeah okay so this one you have to you
have to book beforehand um but yeah you
get I think you yeah what if it's a [__]
film and you're just like stuck in the
lounge being like it was all right you
get one free drink it's could be any
alcoholic beverage you you please and
then afterwards I think you have to pay
but I I'd rather go to Inakaya
afterwards and get as many alcoholic
drinks as you want you know what if you
want to have a hard limit you're like I
want to be around this person for 1 hour
max let's give maybe don't go to the
cinema well no that's why I think like
it's a pretty good date if you wanted to
do it cuz it's like okay you can have
the dinner or whatever or you can just
go to the cinema have the lounge before
and have the lounge after sure sure then
you can just have the you know if you
want to keep I'd do it if it was a
little cheaper I think I think 60 bucks
is kind of okay value I just think that
I'm I I really value a good chair uh and
a and pop from what you but from what
you talk but from what you have
described it's not even that good of a
chair yeah um yeah it's I it would have
been perfect if he had a better chair
it's honestly honestly I'm not kidding
it's the popcorn it's a deal breaker for
me the fact that I can't get more
popcorn that is true I refuse to go to
the cinema if I know cuz during the
pandemic they weren't serving popcorn a
lot of the cinemas uh which I okay sure
yeah uh but I I just didn't want to go
cuz if I can't have the popcorn I don't
want to go genuinely I know that's so
dumb but that's part of the that's part
of the experience for me and having to
be able to like eat that Salted Popcorn
just do and the butter do do you buy
popcorn when you go I know I know you
guys don't but for me that is so so
crucial to my cinema going experience my
reason why I don't like ordering popcorn
at a
is because as you said right it's
usually like The Salted Popcorn right I
don't get I don't get any other the
[__] soy sauce flavored [__] like all
the corns [__] [__] that right you get
eh it's all right but like I prefer like
just the regular Salted Popcorn right
maybe with like a bit of butter if
you're in America but what I don't like
is that okay you're eating all this
popcorn right tastes great [__]
amazing but it's also salty so you got
to have a drink with it yeah of course
my tiny bladder can't hold in a piss if
I start drinking it a so I am know that
if I if I have a bottle of water even if
it's like something this size right and
I drink half of that [__] and halfway
into the film I'm going to be like [__]
I'm going to piss my pants yeah which
results me in missing some of the film
which maybe I don't want to miss it's
like 2 minutes it's like not that bad no
I don't want to well what if it's like
an amazing film I don't want to I always
go and get the cuz Japan they do half
and half popcorns you get caramel and
salted I always get the half and half
and it comes with two mediumsized drinks
I think caramel popcorn's just all right
no but I I love the I love the the
distinction between the two flavors that
I'm eating I love the popcorn this man
is describing popcorn like a
Michelin to me it's so crucial and it's
it's really affordable it's like uh it's
like 12 uh yeah 1,200 Yen uh for that
and like that in the UK that'd be like a
mortgage in 15 like it's like ridiculous
and so I mean I don't have a I don't
have a problem with like the price or
anything or people who eat it I just I
personally just don't do it because I
know that I'm going to have to take a
piss break in the middle and maybe I
don't want to did you guys watch
Godzilla minus one by the way I have not
so [__] good watch it it's really
good it be the hype you reckon yeah it's
a really good film I think that um the
only thing that I I kind of felt like it
it did a little it tried to have too
many Happy Endings when it was a really
like sad film and it kind of tied things
up a little too well I think but that's
like literally my only criticism it was
a really good film and like did you see
Shin Godzilla at all no no I didn't okay
Shin Godzilla was awesome that was
amazing but it's it's kind of refreshing
cuz I I kind of had felt that a lot of
Japanese films for a while I was really
struggling to enjoy and it was really
cool to have it was really you know they
bring out all the stuffs for Godzilla
man dude it was like it was great cuz it
just the I I mean honestly it's so rare
as well to have I feel like Japanese
media kind of just be like yeah the
government is [__]
incompetent uh and it was kind Godzilla
minus one was about it was kind of like
about it was more that's what the entire
Godzilla franchise is about well it was
more about how in the the wake of World
War II how a lot of the rebuilding was
up to the individual people and the
communities coming together Asos oos to
hoping that at least in this obviously
in this this story that they were they
weren't relying on any they were like
yeah the government is going to do [__]
we got to get it done yeah uh and it was
just it was a really cool and like
uplifting story with a lot of heartache
and uh just really well told and
fantastic acting like really good acting
for japanes film it's so interesting to
see the dichotomy between how Godzilla
is treated in Japan versus how Godzilla
is treated in like Hollywood movies like
have you seen like the trailer for the
latest Godzilla movie that's coming out
which the one where he another one
there's another one what the [__] where
it's Godzilla and Kong and they have the
shot yeah they have how many rematches
they have no no no they team up this
time there there's the shot of Godzilla
and Kong running like the oh wait I've
seen this seen like they're coming into
like a WWE match or some some [__] like
that I think I think Godzilla is and
from the Red Corner it's Kong and
Godzilla I think obviously there's some
benefit to keeping your IP in a certain
direction
but
izing where
canes King Kong Godzilla and you can
also have the serious storytelling of of
Godzilla Japan treats it as like you
know how they originally did it with the
the 50s movie which is like you know the
anti-nuclear messaging anti-government
messaging all that kind St I think the
West Hollywood was just like big
Godzilla fights another big monster and
he [__] them up but I think that's why
it works so well is it cuz of the World
War II setting you know rebuilding after
it with the with the anti- nuclear
sentiment of is Godzilla X Kong what is
this a Doan the new Empire basic my
favorite shipping Godzilla and new
Empire the new Empire I mean Godzilla
looks [__] sick in that new visual
it's it's sick it's just a very
different take of Godzilla you guys
should watch minus one I really want
yeah I've heard really good things about
it uh I heard good things and I really
[__] enjoyed Shin Godzilla as well
which is also similar where it's like a
criticism towards the government
specifically their I guess their
reaction towards the Fukushima incident
and use kind of Godzilla as with an Anno
with a good old Anno twist yeah with a
good old ano twist um but other than
that I've put like 40 hours into power
world of course power world the big
thing that has oh yes bro what a [__]
show on Twitter it's crazy cuz like
what's funny is that I T people who
aren't on Twitter yeah and they're like
well I just played the game I thought it
was kind of cool and I was like you know
there's like a [__] stomm going on I
think that's most things nowadays but
it's it's making me appreciate or how
isolated Twitter has become in terms of
public discourse like there are a lot of
people who I guess would kind of It kind
of felt like news used to be on Twitter
and discussing used to be on there but
now it seems to be more so that Twitter
is slowly becoming just rage and what
people are angry about and this has been
the PE Peak example of that especially
with the amount of misinformation going
around you want to know a conspiracy
theory actually uh
think might be actually happening you
heard about like the dead internet
Theory uh I think I actually have heard
of this oh that they're all like Bots
yeah that's I think 90% of replies and
interactions you see online are Bots and
the more I browse Twitter the more I'm
like wait a minute let me get my tinf I
know we had an entire episode on
conspiracy theories but I think this one
this one I'm just like yeah yeah the
dead internet theory is the online
conspiracy theory that asserts that the
internet now consists mainly of Bot
activity and automatically generated
content that is manipulated by
algorithmic curation and I'm like this
is this is just Twitter to a te I mean
it just feels that way cuz people you're
talking to a brain dead I mean if that's
the thing I actually like genuinely
can't tell if people are brain dead or
if they're are Bots because I like how
can you tell the difference I I think
the we need to do like a touring test on
all these like accounts bro we need to
see I just think the worst change they
made was
basically how Twitter handles replies
and handling paid users to appear higher
up bro when I see a blue check mark now
I'm like are you a person or are you a
bot but it just kind of ruined it and it
made it seem that man it just made it a
lot worse cuz it felt like before when a
something kind of reasonable or an
argument was being made that was more
reasonable yeah uh often you know people
would kind of be like yeah that that
makes more sense it's not it's not
inflammatory uh it would kind of get it
would kind of go to the top and it kind
of felt like there was more discourse
whereas now it's more like okay you have
a check mark you saying something
abhorent gets to the front yeah or
you're you just throwing around
accusations goes to the top or whatever
well I think the new check mark on
Twitter now is not the Blue Tick it's
the thing next to the Blue Tick which is
like this account is associated with
this legitimate company what we are like
that's the new one also quote retweets I
think quote retweets is probably one of
the like that becoming a huge thing
became one of the worst things it's it's
it kind of helped in the start to kind
of people who had turned off replies or
were blocking people it was kind of
helpful for allowing people to kind of
call out Bad actors and then it slowly
became this kind of dunking Trend where
now it's all about dunk ratio started
was a fun thing until every tweet was a
ratio yeah you everyone's trying to one
up each other everyone's trying to dunk
on it and you're almost rewarded for
spreading [__] not it it doesn't even
have to be like something opinionated
that you're quot retweeting but like you
can just like it it can just be like oh
I had a nice Daye today and then just
someone quot trating with L plus ratio
you went outside
but like right or wrong it's just been
absolutely fascinating and also super
depressing just seeing the discourse
around this game where everyone is just
arguing about a different thing and no
one just about yeah so okay so oh my God
so I had I had heard about this game
coming out before it actually got
released right I should I should have
prepared a timeline for you but I have
not played the game I've only seen
images of it okay so this game it's
Pokemon with guns right yeah uh yes for
the lack of better word so this game
kind of comes out of nowhere for example
this trailer starts picking up some
steam two or three days before some
creators start getting codes and people
start playing it and realizing hey this
is this is pretty fun yeah H and then it
starts to slowly gain an audience the
game releases and starts selling like
crazy and then this is now where the
eyes of the because I feel like when a
game does well it's it's it does
whatever but then when a game does well
to the point where people who don't care
about games are star to look at it
that's when stuff starts to happen and
obviously it is worryingly similar to
not just Pokémon but a lot of games um
for example you open a chest it sounds
very similar to breath of the wild you
discover a new location very similar to
breath of the wild okay you fight
monsters feels very similar to Monster
Hunter it's like an AI generated game
but yeah and it looks well cuz it's got
that Unreal Engine look okay okay it's
got this unreal unreal engine five right
I think this one yes so it's got this is
like and the problem is because a lot of
asset flips get put into those type of
engines so this kind of has a bad stigma
so it does look kind of bad but it's
very very very similar to Pokemon Aus
right but then the some locations that
look like they've ripped it out of Elden
ring there's some places that I mean and
then it started this whole discourse
then of where because it was such a
popular thing this Twitter kind of it's
and also because you have to remember
now people get paid for having tweets
that get seen a lot that's the wor which
is a which is probably the worst thing
that Twitter could have ever done I
firmly believe that incentivizing people
to get views on Twitter and not just
like have a discourse but like actively
reward money because then that means
people there's no there's no kind of um
you're not like holding yourself
accountable for any reason cuz there's
no before it was just your it was just
your platform it was like but now it's
like there are people out there who have
no no desire to have any kind of shame
or be affected by that it's purely like
how do I make as much money as possible
and and the ad revenue is [__] by the
way I got paid like $19 last month from
X uh yeah you you could sign up for it I
was curious I have as well I think I
think the most I got paid in a month
paid all of December I got $19 I I think
I think December I got paid yeah some
like
$25 basically what ended up happening is
that people were starting to look at it
and people noticed that it looked very
CS just like held off with the fact that
we're getting wait you guys are getting
paid I got like $19 we got pocket chain
from me I got I got one uberit yeah it
was like two meals so obviously you look
at these and you see okay wow these look
there is some kind of inspiration
whether it's plagiarism or not became a
huge argument and that was that was like
the day one argument was is this copying
Pokemon too much day two argument was
they're using AI because the Japanese
crator was kind of uh was pretty vocal
about uh being somewhat supportive uh of
some AI projects but there's no proof
that there's AI in the game sure but of
course Twitter ran with it in started
saying that kind of stuff whether or not
there is or not there might be by the
time this game comes out by the time
this video comes out there might be
proven that there is but the point it
was is that I guess and then a lot of
people got annoyed that it was kind of
being unfair
accused of being using Ai and maybe
stealing for example some mesh models
but then there was some someone later
admitted the guy who had compared the
meshes between a Pokemon and a pal he
had resized or kind of done something
there was this whole weird thing where
everyone was arguing different arguments
all at the same time and then there was
a a fan base of people who were like I
don't care what the [__] they did as
long as they make Nintendo make a fun
game cuz this [__] is way more fun than
any Nintendo game and so then there was
this argument going on and it's kind of
become just absolute [__] show where
everyone is shouting different things
into the void and different people feel
like they should defend different things
um and the ultimate question is like
does it yeah but plag but it's a fun
game and that's the worst part of it
there we go how's the game done and DED
and the worst part is that I think that
they are definitely I mean from a
personal perspective they definitely
feels way too close to to Pokemon and
certain things I think the only argument
I that is kind of valid in this instance
at least for me personally is the
comparison between Pokemon games right
in the sense that like you know as a
Pokemon fan myself I think this game
being so successful and it being
compared to Pokémon I think is a good
wakeup call for Nintendo that's what a
lot of people are arguing but a lot of
people like yeah you can you can say
that without arguing that like no you
can't because this is Nintendo we're
talking about would you say the let's
say the feel and the you know feeling of
plagiarism or like cuz there's always a
question between plagiarism yeah it's
I'm inspiration I'm playing it and it
feels uncomfortably close like you even
like breath of the wild like but then
again it's the same question of cuz I I
remember this is it plagiarism or is it
inspiration no cuz I I remember this
kind of discussion happening when genin
first released if you if it's it's if if
you think that this is like plagiarizing
for example like breath of the wild then
I guess you'd it would have to be the
it's the the same level as genin of like
but then like open world games that you
can explore that's not something you can
plagiarize is it like a similar style
and approach to how breath of the wild
did it yes I think so but the same way
that genin is and again I'm not trying
to defend this were open wall games
before birth of the wild I'm not trying
to defend this game but um like I think
cuz it's the Pokemon coll is way too
close it's way way way way too close
yeah cuz like I'm looking just like at
some of these pictures and I'm looking
at some of these monsters and I'm like
oh that looks like that Pokemon that
looks like that looks like Lucario the
[__] there's the one that looks like ret
up there there's just some things that
they did that just baffles me why they
did the exact like Lea do you know what
this looks like um like you know
sometimes you're browsing on YouTube or
some [__] site you shouldn't be on
and you see this ad of this weird mobile
game that gets advertised you know you
know what I mean the one that looks like
a Pokemon game right no no no it could
be like any mobile like any weird mobile
game or it's like a [__] maybe it's a
league ripoff or maybe it's a Pokemon
ripoff AIC ripoff and you're like there
is no way this game exists and then you
look into it and it's just like oh this
is just a fake build whatever but it
kind of feels like the creators have
just looked at all the games they like
and just taken every single aspect from
every game they like and shoved it into
one but also maybe kind of copied the
style of all those things a little too
much like like I was mentioning earlier
there's some things they copied too much
which I think were just completely
unnecessary to copy um like when you
when you catch a a mon or Pal or
whatever you want to call it a mon I I
call them mons because I refused to call
them pal because it reminds me too much
of Chris Chan and I don't like calling
them because he calls everyone Pals um I
that's a you problem yeah it is actually
a problem like the ball when you throw
it it Wiggles three times you could have
just not done that like why did you hear
it's like if you wanted to avoid the
plagiarism accusations why would you
make it so that so many little things
and even just the fact you have to throw
a ball-shaped thing in order to catch it
as well I mean it's kind of it's kind of
hard and I get that's kind of
unavoidable but um at least change the
shape you know make it a cube or
something and like I don't think little
things like that would have been bad if
they hadn't have had so many designs
that are too closely inspired but then a
lot of people argued that then the
designs are inspired Pokemon designs are
inspired from yo-kai or mythology and
dragon real animals or real animals even
like people were arguing that the sheeps
look to the same to the Pokemon sheep
people like it's a [__] sheep dog
which I agree with yeah um and I think
that I think you can have the same
conversation of the sheeps don't aren't
a [__] copy but hey that Lucario
looks awfully a lot like the Lucario
well I mean I'm I'm I'm just looking at
this right go to the top image like that
third one there that straight up looks
like Leafeon yeah absolutely like it's
not even like I think I think you can
say that they copied they not copied but
ins even the color palette is exactly
the same as Leaf some of the things are
I I think even if it there is no legal
battle here right I think as a as a
consumer you can be like yeah this feel
a little too close but at the same time
Pokemon fans are so starved for a good
[__] game that I think they are just
rejoicing at the fact that they
basically get to get the game they
wanted I I agree look as weird yeah I
think as a Pokémon fan I think this game
becoming successful is great for the
Pokémon Community because it is putting
pressure I think or I'd like to hope it
is putting pressure until Nintendo sues
but I think it's putting pressure on
Nintendo to be like hey make a [__]
good game but I don't think that that
has to mean that the company's success
is uh we should be super uh ah it's so
tough cuz I think that statement can
exist whilst also being like hey you
guys took a little too much well I think
like objectively like what this proved
uh you know is there is a huge gap in
the market you know there is I I don't
think I mean okay people are getting mad
because this game got popular of course
and I don't think there would be this
entire discourse around it if this game
wasn't breaking records left right and
Center oh yeah if this if this had FedEd
into security no one would give [__]
yeah and I think the reason this is
breaking records left right and Center
is because there is a clear Gap in the
market of what people want in their
video games we just w we just want a
Pokemon game in Unreal Engine 5 that's
what we've been it it was like put
together by a bunch of Japanese students
and one of them was like a comini worker
student who was like oh yeah I can make
guns and he just made the guns and
apparently the reason they added guns to
the game was because they said Americans
like to shoot things um and I'm in
proven right I'm inclined to agree with
them because there's just like [__]
be thing I mean I I just unlocked that
Gatling gun uh and yeah you literally
can just gun down these things uh and
it's it's insane and it's very fun I I
think all the clips I've seen of power
world it just you know you know it's
it's a game that okay there's this thing
about plagiarism taking things from
different games it just seems like a
game that hits every single gamer
Instinct you could ever put have in one
single game The Base building is really
fun you have a base that you build and
you essentially make factory base
building cute monsters and when you
catch them it's not like in you know
it's like in uh in Pokemon where you
catch these thing and you only use like
the six in your party you make them work
you put them to work in your base and
like you make them mine you make them
cut wood you make them make food you do
all go my slaves yeah it's like it lit
literally this a [__] eim you can
also catch people I don't know if you
knew this uh you catch people so you can
actually make real slaves you can catch
people you can sell them for money and
you can make them work for free wait I I
think I think minut got reminds me of
something but the pokemonism you can
also butcher the people and the Pokemon
for resources uh as well holy [__] I
call them Pokemon but yeah you
know wow is nothing like Pokemon yeah I
mean it yeah it just seems like a game
where I mean look at that thing that
just [__] it's it's a car crash of
different genres and different and it's
also so buggy it's so [__] funny you
just you'll hit an enemy sometime
that'll fly away and you're like okay
how many hours have you put into it like
40 I'm like nearly done with it nearly
like I've nearly got everything but
what's also great is that like you could
just have like five of your friends come
just [__] B come in the world and
[__] chill
out which is what they what they try to
do do like a monster hunter esque raid
where you're all trying to catch this
one thing and it might have like a 1%
chance but you have to make the balls as
well you can't buy them you have to make
them so you have to you have to like
really manage your resources and again
that was something Pokémon tried to do
with the newest game and it just
completely [__] failed well arus felt
so like
kind of even Violet and Scarlet with the
multiplayer segment it was just so like
unintuitive and the fact that that
because it's on Steam I can literally
just be like hey Joe join my world pop
you're in you're in two seconds yeah
yeah and you can join anytime there's no
weird kind of restrictions and it's and
you can also they allow you to adjust
all the settings of the server so if you
want to get XP way faster you can do it
if you want to catch stuff easier if you
want to get more drops right if you want
to like creative mode yeah there's like
there's like raids on your base you can
turn them off so while you're out they
might might come and raid your base to
quickly get back and save your base from
being demolished it's PR [__] cool
like there it's a like such a cool game
idea that is kind of unfortun many
mechanics point it's unfortunately has
this cloud of did it copy too much um
and it's you know it's kind of you think
most people care about that no no I I
think there is this unfortunate lack of
caring from consumers that don't care
about how their art is made and how it's
consumed um
and I think it's a shame but it's also
how it's always been the consumer rarely
cares about how art is made they just
want it made and it's it's almost like
shatting at a brick wall hoping that the
consumer will care about where their art
comes from yeah you know there are some
people who look look at a painting or
look at a 3D model of a of a a game
they'll look at this you know like Elden
ring you might look at a boss and like
someone might look at that and think
holy [__] the amount of work that must
have gone into design must model anim
made rig this thing must have been
absolutely painstaking and must and a
lot of people have interest learning
that and other people do not give a [__]
and they just think that this thing gets
made and it's made because it got made
and they don't realize that maybe a boss
character took thousands of Collective
hours and painstaking work to make it
come to life like that is kind of sounds
like the anime Community doesn't it it's
same same as we have proven time and
time again with with the animator
situation yeah consumers do not give a
[__] how the thing gets made as long as
it gets made as long as the end product
is good and it is so unfortunate because
I I think that I'd love for this W to
coexist where we could have everyone
care about how the art is made you know
and I think to I watch all K did I have
a moral obligation to not do that I
don't know it's weird like I don't know
where I don't know what I should and
shouldn't do all I know is that it's bad
and we want it to change so much so that
every single time my [__] little pals
are walking away everyone's like oh it's
a mappa studio in there like that's
become synonymous now with like horrible
working conditions like it's a joke now
like what is the what like what is the
they fail to realize that it's still an
actual massive problem that is outside
of that immediate thing as well I guess
that's why it's so hard to really get
invested in this cuz you don't know I
don't know what the right stance is to
take even with what you describe with
power I don't even know what the problem
is not not like I don't know what the
core problem I don't know what like the
singular problem is cuz it seems like
there are multiple problems being and
everyone's fighting a different thing
and you're like and at the end of the
day consumer is going to see that [__]
show going on this one little side of
the internet and be like [__] this [__]
I'm just going to play the game yeah and
at the end of the day the power creators
are just raking in the money from the
amount of hype and 200 million in sale
so far the second most concurrent
players of any steam game ever um it's
it's the the the success of this game is
something we've never seen before yeah
this is truly like on another level um
and it's
frustrating as being like an our
position as well because I want to make
sure that you know with our platform and
what I'm doing is that we're sending out
the right message there and that that we
we care about artists and how art is
made I think it's important to care
about how art is made but I don't I
don't know as somebody who is in this
weird kind of commentary kind of not in
the process but a consumer and a lot of
people's viewing point of how like the
where this like a lot of people might
experience the art through me
interacting with it in some sense how do
I have a responsible way of sharing that
I don't know it's well I me how do how
do you talk about judu kaon without the
thing right it's difficult as you said
like you know some people are obviously
going to care about the underlying
problems that are legitimate problems
but it's also very difficult to try and
convince people on how they should think
or you know what stance they should take
because this is the internet everyone's
[__] opinionated they're not going to
budge just because someone told them
that they should think a certain way you
know there's nothing unfortunately
there's nothing we can do about that
yeah it's also a shame because I I feel
like sometimes I feel like man I feel
like um I sometimes have the wrong
mindset on this as well where I think
maybe I'm part of the problem when I'm
consuming this anime and I think that
but it's really [__] good and how do
I change how do I change my perspective
on that cuz I don't know like I like I
I'm watching this thing and I I'm and I
hear about these stories and I want to
know how the [__] do I what is the best
thing to do here I don't know and how do
I change my mind about how I feel about
this how do I feel about this media I
personally you should uh worry less
about what other what other people
perceive you because I'm sure we might
have said something in here that would
have offended some people but you get to
a point and at least I had this
realization yeah you get to a point when
you realize you know people look at us
with a big reach but even with a reach
are big we can only we can only do so
much and it's it's a it's a it's an
unwinable game of just always being able
to figure out what to do what is the
right thing to do about a certain topic
there are some certain topics we know
more about there are some certain topics
we don't know more about what I've come
to value is an acting change that's I
have control of there are some things
where it's frustrating because you feel
like it's out of your control
and you want there to be changed but
there's just control there and the more
the more I realize what I can control
and what I can't control the more like
with power world I can't [__]
control I I can't [__] control that
and there is this argument about is this
is it ethical to consume or not and at
the end of the day i' like personally
like if you choose to consume it or
don't consume it personally I don't I
don't know how much of a big difference
you can make yeah also we're in the
middle of it so it could be in 5 years
from now there might be a
clear you know consensus yeah we're too
far into the the gray zone of this right
now where we don't know if there's an
actual correct right or WR one thing
that that pisses me off sometimes when
I'm I'm like playing a [__] video
game and someone's like hey you should
talk about this thing and I'm like I'm
what do you want me to say yeah I I am
like I'll talk about it if I want to
talk about it like I I like what is me
going to do talking about this thing to
this audience like who already have
already probably met their own mind have
their own personal opinions about it
it's like me I am like the McDonald's
equivalent of like a on the Michelin
star Chef world like I'm at the bottom
of this chain of producing slop
essentially people I've come to notice
people who ask that kind of [__] to you
uh they don't actually want to hear your
opinion they are either sitting on
either side of the fence and they want
to hear someone that they admire and get
validation from them really I feel like
sometimes people just want you to agree
with them and say the thing they agree
with well no yeah that's exactly what it
is and it's like you know it's like if
you're sitting on one side of the fence
or the other and like I go up to you for
example and say like hey can you talk
about this issue which side do you agree
with if you agree with my side then
great the ship is sailing if I don't
agree with if I don't agree with
whatever you say oh there another reason
to hate you you know and it's like well
then what the [__] either way I'm not
winning because I'm throwing myself into
this conversation that I didn't want to
throw myself into that's why you haven't
heard anything from me yet if I wanted
to join the conversation you didn't have
to ask me I would have said something
it feels like you know with especially
with something like Twitter or modern uh
problems it seems like everyone needs to
have an opinion I think everyone just
needs I I I think the world can actually
you know move on more if you a lot of
people realize you don't have to have an
opinion about everything you know you
can do your best to be educated but
we're all [__] human you know there's
only so much we can intake and so much
we can emotionally get invested in and
care about you know there are some
issues that unfortunately I have no
personal investment in you know as much
as uh you know because in this day and
age it seems like I need to be invested
in everything going on all around the
world it's hard uh and no one person can
do that I don't think the human brain
can truly comprehend this many issues
and not go [__] crazy or go depressed
absolutely unfortunately so it's been
yeah it's been a weird game and it's
kind of made a lot of interesting
conversation all right enough talking
about [__] internet fights angry
people angry people I want to talk about
real fights with real men what um
because uh I had a mate come visit me in
Thailand uhhuh and uh to
a well we might we might have got we
might have done with the amount of
[__] adrenaline running through our
veins okay cuz I took him to a Muay Thai
fight oh [__] yeah and it was actually
my very first Muay Thai like my first
Tha I've seen it a lot on TV but I've
never actually like gone out of my way
to watch a fight in real life um and I
don't know something something uh next
time you guys are in silent I got to
[__] take you in one because
something clicked in my brain that I
didn't know was there um it's like I
just want to kick a dude yeah so so
basically uh we got like ringside seats
uh to one it was it was a Sunday event
so it was like a it was a televised
event sure right um and watching two men
just [__] beat the [__] out of each
other uh and sitting why Bey so popular
I don't [__] like I okay I've I've
seen fights I've seen like boxing I've
seen contact Sports before and it's like
cool in the moment and you're like ah
I'm okay I don't know I I like it I can
I can watch it but I'm not like into
into it but like just see being ringside
and just hearing every single punch and
just seeing the sweat you know you know
in you know in [__] Sports Anime or
like you know a sports film where like
someone gets punched and you see like
The Sweat Just explode everywhere like
seeing that in real life made me
realize why like you know it made me
feel like being a Roman watching like
going to the Coliseum some [__] like
that this is the closest I've seen to
like real blood Sports up close sure and
uh yeah
just I'm I'm I'm like a bit I I guess
Muay Thai is like pretty popular right
but it's not as obviously it's not as
widespread in televised as it is in
Thailand and it is just such a fun
contact sport where oh I bet I I was
there and I was like I don't know if
we're going to see some good matches or
not we had we had um eight eight matches
um four of them ended out ended up in
Knockouts like oh damn wow hell yeah
yeah and and was uh talking to one of
the event organizers and they were like
oh yeah today was a pretty tame day
actually not oh my God like that today
was a pretty tame day brain damage the
sport not a single broken bone what was
tame day I literally I've seen so many
I've seen so many [__] Joe Rogan
Clips talking about like the brutality
of Muay Thai and then seeing like like
you you get to a point where there's
there's an opportunity where if if a guy
gets hit right you will literally you
have a chance of getting [__] blood
in your blood in your uh beer or some
[__] like that it is it is in your beer
yeah yeah it is it is that like it is
that brutal and they and they go that
hard but also there a bunch of tie guys
just like sitting there being like
wasn't the same today no blood in my
beer no blood in my beer yeah I don't
know there's just something bring the
Poncho yeah rain coat yeah but uh yeah
so it was it was my first Muay Tha
experience and I I I honestly think now
that everyone should go see cuz like you
want to see the you went you got to see
sit ringside on the YouTuber chess
boxing right I did yeah F how much of an
adrenaline rush did you get from
watching that I mean it's just intense
and you feel bad you almost feel bad for
the people cuz you can hear all the
punches connecting on TV you don't hear
that yeah but you hear the like all the
little noises and it almost makes it
like worse and better at the same time
cuz you're like it makes you really
uncomfortable with the idea of watching
people just beat the [__] out of each
other yeah
um that's how I felt when we went to go
see the Sumo as well live like I've seen
it on TV so many times but just
especially that first initial impact of
when the match starts it is so loud
there was there was just this like kind
of a that I think people and humans just
have with beating each other up or
sports that require you to throw each
other around or something something in
your monkey that's why world something
in your monkey brain that just sees two
people hitting each other like I
remember this one I remember this one
fight where um there's this one guy who
just seemed to be tanking kicks yeah
right I like every everyone in there is
hard as a [__] hard as a [__]
I I use hard in like the [__] British
way yeah hard as a [__] um like
they like there are we we went we went
on a day was that was meant to be like
the amateur fights right and these
amateur fights there were these like 16
18 year olds that have been in 40
matches at the they they literally felt
like a baky character because you see
this 16-year-old walk in and you're like
his dad's just been fighting with his
dad the night
before I actually I actually cuz uh me
and my M had a few drinks before and and
he posed this question to me right he
was like all right Real Talk how many
eight-year-olds do you think you can
feasibly beat in a fight like H how like
what's what's all attacking yeah if
you're if they were all attacking you at
the same time how many eight-year-olds
do you think you can beat in I think
after 10 I'm done would you you're
satisfied no no no as in like I'll be
dead do they have weapons no no no all
hand F just fist all hand to hand
combats I think after 10 it'll get too
overwhelming you think you can take on
10 because here here's the thing here's
the thing I don't know how skilled are
these 8-year-olds I feel like I could
beat up a lot more than 10 yeah okay
listen the if okay the one the one thing
that would hold you back is would your
hands start hurting too much have
punching so many kids in the face yeah
but you assume okay here's the thing
right okay what am I assuming what am I
assuming I'm missing something you
assume that you can deck a kid and he
will stay down in one hit right cuz
that's that's the thing if if there are
too if there are too many 8-year-olds
that like jump you at the same time
they're going to eventually overpower
you right yeah that's true actually so
you like the the Strat am I allowed to
kick yeah you're allowed to kick you can
do whatever the [__] you want oh they're
dunzo the the Strat is can you can you
like can you completely knock out one
kid in one hit and how many times can
you do that in a row cuz if they get up
they're eventually just going to [__]
drag you down tie you out it's going to
be like an arcade machine each one they
come near me I'll kick them in Oblivion
just just coffee grind sweep all their
legs out and they just go one by one
these the legs that did the cyclon these
are big legs I it's like the force of
Zeus in this kid's face like Michael
like like Atlas if you put down the bowl
and start throwing hands like that's
seen in 300
you dude I mean I I think I could knock
out kid instantly what do you mean but I
think you don't think you could knock
out a kid instantly why do why like this
is the most trash T disgusting no here
we're logistically talking about child
AB 8-year-old 8-year-old what do the
what the average weight and size of an
8-year-old bring it up I want to be
scient see that's why I said 10 cuz I
think I think like I do
30y old and then give me a five minute
give me a five minute uh I think
8-year-olds can get stronger than you
think give me a give me like a I need
games like realistic battle simulator
are answer these question can I get that
in real units please yeah no no no
pounds no pounds because if that as long
as they I mean obviously they'd be
hitting my balls 20 kilos yeah lowest
that's one hand 20 to 30 kilos dude I
can launch 20
kilos I could throw a kid into the into
the other kids and keep throwing them
around yeah but like tired that' the
biggest thing my Stam you would get
tired right so so what's going to run
out first the vitality
I'm like I'm not talking about how many
8-year-olds oneon-one fight can you do
in a row I'm talking about they they try
to jump you and you have to like
strategically try to take on what's my
battlefields what's what's my battle all
right ma where am I fighting I want
think Super Smash Bros Final Destination
no items yeah yeah yeah right it's a
flat ground flat ground I can jump to a
platform though right there's a platform
above me no
platform literally just just flat flat
ground it's like a [__] you're in the
middle I just have to edgu guard them
and they're done you're in a park and
and and these kids are like you know
they're not built like a backy character
but what is happening to what happened
to on trash St it doesn't matter we're
talking about real discussions here real
discussions with I said 10 right because
I think like five for instance right is
I think is doable right I mean it won't
be easy but I think it'll be doable I
think five is I think 10 though is the
limit where like if there's 10
8-year-olds running up to you in all
directions how are you going to start
just think about this can I kill them
okay
okay yeah yeah you can kill them but but
let's assume these are like not real
kids these aren't real kids these are
like what's the most effective way
that's what I'm saying coffee grind
coffee grind just coffee grind sweep out
all their feet so they fall to the
ground and then just take them on one by
one this feels like a fear and hunger
enemy actually your foe in the dungeon
15 kids 15 kids armored up cuz we had
this discussion and he posed to me the
question okay but like would you like
would you think the same if they were
monkeys could you think about monkeys
and they're like [__] no monkeys would
have monkeys I don't I'm I'm just going
I don't even think I can take on one
monkey everyone Tails a game changer
Tails a game changer everyone thinks
they can take take on like 10 20 to
8year olds but you you switch them to
monkeys cuz monkeys can [__] pounce
and they can jump very fast I don't even
think I can beat one monkey all it takes
is one monkey on your face yeah one
monkey on your face and it's done yeah
monke three four or five times stronger
than a human dude oh one okay 1.2 to 1.5
you literally read out the misconception
[__] sake I didn't read why did they
phrase the sentence like that with this
is not true okay what if I just like
grabbed one kid okay let's say 10 kids
run at me I grabb one kid throw them at
the kids to get as many of them out of
the way as I can grab another kid grab
my pile driver's head into the ground
presumably he's out by okay what if you
grab the one of the kids by the the leg
and you just like windmilled around just
like that honestly if you try to pick
someone up by the leg I haven't but if
you try to move someone by the leg it's
very hard Okay just grab by the sounds
killed someone it's honestly very it's
much better than I know from
experience you I I feel like you have an
easier time for you like if he was
wearing clothes you pick him up by the
coat or shirt whatever you [__]
launch [__] launch but just shot his
ass but like if if if you don't [__]
knock him out he's going to get back up
and start jumping you again and again I
think that will do
you can do the cheesing thing that you
do in fighting games where you just keep
doing the low kick where you like low
kick their leg but you low kick their
face like Bo boom K them away just don't
let them get on you I think you can do
it eventually they're going to start
either crying or get knocked down I
don't think throwing the kid into
another kid is going to do much damage
to either throw into the wall
right I mean I gu well okay what you're
in Final Destination there's no wall any
T think you right you just have like no
weapons right and it's n 10 is my limit
yeah
I
think I'd say eight eight to 10 I think
20 20 20 God I'd love to see that let's
arrange it I speci I don't think you can
like I don't think you can like 88y olds
want to get beaten up contact trash
taste if it was 10-year-old it'd be a
lot less but 8-year-old that's pretty
sure what's the difference between those
two years can we get a can you show a
comparative age uh in picture uh
8-year-old vers adult 8-year-old versus
adult size just so cuz like eighty olds
are pretty small I think the're olds
they they grow through growthy old
eighty olds are small but I don't I
don't think you get a growth but at age
10 no it's pretty big difference really
bro that that is actually pretty big
that's pretty big that's pretty big
actually pretty you can take on 20 okay
10 10 10 yeah right I think you thinking
about todders at this I think think
you're like 5year olds yeah 5-year-olds
I could take like yeah 5-year-olds okay
yeah 5-year-olds okay 10-year-old do
10-year old yeah average height of a 10y
old 10y old they start to grow a lot
more like in 138 C show image maybe 140
cm yeah I feel like I would yeah maybe
I'm I'm overzealous I'm over 32 kilos
140 cm so what's what what's that like
maybe about that that's pretty big
that's I think I was Conor siiz if one
of them gets a good wow if one of them
gets a good nut shot on me it's game
over you know so I kind have to they are
they are at perfect nut height as how
this come out um because we were seeing
how many [__] shots these kids were
tanking how how old are they huh they
like 16 15 16 to 18 and I'm like and I'm
like what because we could you could
hear the impact of every thought and
sometimes sometimes like people were
getting like obviously hit in the face
they can tank it in the face but it was
like the body shots right because with
tie with my Thai uh cuz I've done a bit
in BO Tha and when when you when you do
a kick it's almost like it's the same
power as just getting a baseball bat
just well it's like cuz they like whip
their feet right yeah it's almost like a
whip motion you whip your feet and you
hear this impact and it literally sounds
like someone just took a baseball bat
and just [__] tried to crack their
real they
[Laughter]
whip visualize all the little bones in
your body to make a whip yeah and I
remember this one fight where this guy
just which which always which I guess
comes down to like the mental game as
well this one guy just seemed to be
tanking kicks and it did not seem to be
affecting him at all no yeah to the
point where like you could visually see
how red his body was right you you you
could see it and we were like what how
the hell is he still standing and like
he and he looked unfaced right he looked
unfazed and all it took was like one
kick in the fourth round and it wasn't
even the hardest kick but he just like
he just he just [__] fell over went
live and I'm like exists he's in
Thailand nor can't just take kicks for
free a reason why you us a
Dodge yeah I I mean it's it's a bit sad
because we went to like a very local
stadium and normally you know this
stadium was famous for being able to all
the local tie people coming to watch but
it has very much been transformed to be
more Foreigner friendly the ticket
prices is not anything that uh you know
the locals can afford unfortunately um
but it was it was funny because they had
like whenever they'd introduce fighter
they'd have like a tie announcer and
they'd have like you know a typical like
English speaking announcer as well oh
wow and the the tier was like you know
Thailand we are like very respectful
country we're like okay so the next
fighter is this person he grew up from
this province his name is this how come
they're really respectful here but then
when I'm trying to get in the taxi it
feels like there is just nothing but
disrespect yo when it comes to martial
arts that's where dude is that where all
the respect way what the heck that's
called
xenophobia they were nice they just
hustle and then you hand it over to like
the Foreigner and he's like and coming
into the Red
Corner the man from Thailand it's just
like we we love the shows with fighter
wees his name it's just like the sheer
dichotomy between the energy between how
the you how the ti fight it's Monday
Monday mu Thai night
but uh like this there's one fight that
stood out to me wasn't anything actually
to do with the fight right because there
was this one fight where it was it was I
guess uh I think this kid was like 16 or
something like that and imagine it it's
a packed Stadium right it's a pack
Stadium everyone's cheering on every
single hit every punch and this one
voice just pierces through everything
and it's the kid's
mom oh no and and Jesus and like me and
my M had bets on like who which fighter
would win and uh I bet like I bet
against that kid right and then just
seeing the mom uh just like just seeing
the mom and I I listened he was like no
no no hook left hook left upera upera no
Dodge Dodge and like and and just like
it I that would drive me insane if my
mom was back
seating it almost made me [__] tear
up cuz like just like seeing the mom
just support like I can't imagine how it
is as a parent seeing your kid in the
ring getting beat up getting beat up man
must be horrible and just seeing the mom
just fully commit to supporting this kid
um who thankfully actually won his fight
in the end nice yeah [__] the other kid
and his mom [__] his mom wasn't there
his mom wasn't there that's why you
should always go to your sons or
daughters games cuz they'll win exactly
they'll win of parents they they will
win and uh they if if you can hear them
I I don't know if the kid could hear the
person or not um because I don't I can't
imagine how focused you need to be on
the ring my God probably had like a
Raging Bull moment where he's just like
he heard the mom like I have to do it
for my family damn well that was that
was epic I highly recommend going to
more contact Sports I I think I'm going
to do it now as well it's well next well
we know what we're doing next time we're
in Thailand yeah hell yeah and uh how
many how many 8-y olds can we be inight
I said 10 you said eight you said say 11
just
just a oneup
joey but thank you so much for watching
appreciate it don't forget to buy the
merch while you still can it's the last
opportunity to grab it we will not be
bringing it back this is for some reason
this is the one day that Connor decided
not to wear I thought we weren't doing a
topical episode this week I didn't know
we were going to be doing a fast release
episode so my bad I would have warned
the Shir if I had known but you can get
it your last chance ever to your last
chance it's Conor's last chance as well
this is this is no joke but when we
decided that we will bringing this you
know the OG apari run back Connor
literally said in a slack threads can I
get 30 of those sh I for 30 of them I
get 30 I'm getting 30 I thought I
thought I I put 20 and I sat there and I
put and I removed it he's literally
trying to do B movie in real life yeah
I'm going to have all of the t-shirts in
my collection you know do you know what
that NG reminded me of have you watched
park parks and rexor or any yeah yeah
yeah you know you know that uh there's
this clip where is this Nam Ron Swanson
yeah Ron Swanson yeah where Ron Swanson
like goes to like a diner and he goes
give me all of the bacon that you have
the guy walks away he goes no no no no
no come back I I'm afraid you misheard
give me a lot of bacon what I said was
give me all of the bacon and that's the
same energy I felt when Connor was like
I want 30 shirts and he goes no no no
really I
want not around 30 I want 30 I want 30 I
want I'm telling you I I've worn out my
current shirts too much I do want to
throw them away or I might give them
away if I want them uh because I there's
holes in them and the neck has been
ruined so I kind of just want to get a
new shirt so do you want that shirt
among all these other it it's your final
chance so get it uh but hey look at all
these patrons though all I'm sure let us
know in the comments how many
8-year-olds you can beat up cuz I'm
curious we should pull our patrons see
how many yeah pull the what is the
optimal Strat please please give give us
what your Strat would be to take on as
many eighty olds as possible thanks so
much for watching if you want to support
us then make sure to go over to our
patreon patreon.com trast also follow us
on Twitter send us memes on the
subreddit if you had a face listen TOS
on Spotify and uh hey we have a brand
new patreon exclusive video up right now
as well so go check that out link is in
the description yeah here's a preview
right now hey you guys want to join in
no no Joey Joey you got this I'm I'm I'm
in my we're going to be interacting with
people a lot of people actually they're
already lining up out there waiting for
us so so uh of the worst of all
Australia all you see
hi anyways boys thank you guys for
joining in and we will see you all next
week bye
[Music]
bye